Speaker 1: So now a fight broke out at another
one of these school board meetings about masks,
and it was happening while a local reporter
was interviewing doctors about them being
assaulted.
And that was interrupted by a fight, a shoving
match of some kind.
And we're going to get to that video in a
moment.
You might remember that back in June, I did
a story that on YouTube we called covid has
made people insane.
And in that story, I explain how there's been
a dramatic increase to the frequency of people
becoming completely dysregulated in public
in the era of the pandemic.
And we've talked about unruly passengers on
airplanes being reported to the FAA.
We've talked about fan behavior at sporting
events, fights, people running into the fields,
road rage incidents all over the place, all
of these wild events at grocery stores over
masks.
There's the racist traitor Joe video we did
that went viral.
And I said that there's really a few things
going on here.
One part of it was that because of the pandemic,
many people just got used to not being around
other people and not having to behave.
And now that they're back around people, they've
sort of forgotten how to behave.
Then there are people for whom the pandemic
has just sort of been like a throw decorum
out the window moment and they don't care
about behaving anymore.
Some of them are furious about the pandemic.
Some of them are furious about shutdowns.
And instead of just being glad that maybe
we can start getting back to things as people
get vaccinated, they're going nuts and they're
taking out their fury on other people.
For others, there's kind of the difficulty
of reintegrating after being just afraid of
doing things because many people were afraid
of the world out there, was trying to kill
me, is the way it felt to many during the
heat of the virus, which we're sort of getting
back into.
I'm acting like we're beyond it, but we're
not.
And there's a sort of like PTSD type thing
that's taking place and it's coming out in
weird ways for others.
I think the becoming unaccustomed to being
in groups has maybe created like an agoraphobia.
So some people are staying home because of
it.
Some people are feeling stressed when they're
out and then people are lashing out.
But then there's also specifically people
like those were about to look at here who
were just triggered by having to deal with
the pandemic and the fact that there are masks
that are being discussed and in some places
required, that there is this issue of getting
people vaccinated.
Even if you don't want to, you might have
to in order to work here or to send your kid
there.
And it's leading to dozens and dozens of incidents
at school board meetings and public health
events and the like.
And that gets us to today's incident.
It was complete and total pandemonium at the
Lee County School Board meeting.
We played some clips from this earlier.
This was a meeting where the superintendent
announced a massive mandate, not rare.
Many schools are doing it and a doctor was
assaulted.
And there were a bunch of different fights
that broke out, including this one on live
TV.
Now, what we're going to see is the reporter
is interviewing, I think, a doctor about how
they were assaulted.
And in the meantime, that conversation about
an assault is interrupted by people fighting.
And the audio tells you a bunch of it.
But I'm describing it in case you're only
listening today.
Let's take a look.
Let's take a listen.
Happen in your reaction.
Speaker 3: So actually, Dr. Ballasts got shot.
She was actually I was just trying to make
my way to the door so I could come in and
fill a comment.
Speaker 1: Now, I the subtitles said that
the doctor got shot.
I believe it's actually the doctor got shoved
Speaker 3: and a woman stood in front of me
and bumped me out of the way.
I was trying to get Cindy Benyus attention
and tell her hello and thank you for coming.
Yeah.
And a woman pushed her body into me.
Speaker 1: So are you shocked at what is now
the reporters already distracted?
Because there's the screaming in the background
is building into a melee and the reporter
tries to keep going.
But here you'll see he just can't focus anymore.
Speaker 3: Just become not at all been watching
it on social media for weeks and months and
months.
I'm not
Speaker 2: OK.
Right, right here.
Look right here.
So as you can see, fists are now flying.
All of this on live television.
Fists are flying.
Oh, my God.
Unbelievable what we are seeing here today
unfold live.
Speaker 1: Now, four sheriff's officers are
getting involved to try to break up the fight.
Speaker 2: Now we can see the sheriff's deputies
are coming out here to get between the two
groups.
A lot of confusion, a lot of anger.
A lot of deputies now are finally pouring
in to see.
Speaker 1: Now, you know, the truth is Lee
County is actually doing something.
They're trying to do something that that might
make a difference because covid is completely
out of control.
In Lee County, Florida, cases have been spiking
to what are easily the pandemic.
High numbers.
It's total chaos.
It's pandemonium.
It's bedlam.
School board meetings across the country are
going to start needing security or for the
ones that already have security, they're going
to start eating more security as the case.
Maybe this has to stop or it has to be stopped
somehow.
Right.
Even if you think that as a parent, you're
doing something good for your kid by acting
out against masks, don't you think it's even
bad for the kid to know that their mom or
dad is losing their mind and protesting and
humiliating themselves on TV or in front of
the community?
Like, however annoying you think wearing the
mask is for your kid and for most kids, it
doesn't seem very annoying, quite frankly.
Isn't that not as bad as a kid being like,
oh, no, mom is doing it again?
Mom's in a fight at the school board meeting.
Dad is talking about dads wearing a hazmat
suit and talking about Hitler at a school
board meeting.
It seems to me that that would be much, much
worse.
And it's not only embarrassing for the individuals,
it's embarrassing for the country at a global
scale.
They're laughing at us around the world.
But it's also really sad and bad for the kids
as well.
It's all
of it, all of the above.